[Música]
soy comediante soy comediante soy
comediante soy comediante soy comediante
soy comediante
[Música]
Hola chicos De dónde son son de Los
Ángeles
Sacramento eres de Sacramento en Los
Ángeles soy de California
en todas partes en eventos privados
fiestas de cumpleaños cosas así fiestas
Qué tipo de fiesta de cumpleaños amigos
de familia Michelle dijo que hace
cumpleaños y eventos familiares no dejo
que mi familia me vea hacer comedia y
menos reunirlos y decirles chistes solo
frente a tu familia es mi peor pesadilla
bueno en mi familia hay comediantes y
son algo locos Cuando cierras el show
dos minutos
cuando me digan cuando le hicieron la
pregunta Ella dijo cuando me digan pensé
eso no pasa uno yo soy igual cuando un
minuto si soy el principal unos 10
minutos si no lo soy dos
cuándo empezaste a hacer comedia
[Música]
nací así así Empecé
con el estando el año pasado pero tengo
en la comedia 7 u 8 años con el estado
desde el año pasado
[Música]
es muy simpática es amable lo que ella
es una bandera roja
No creo que tenga mucho trabajo en la
comedia con cumpleaños
[Música]
preciosa chica hermosa
Isabella yo sí quiero saber algo Puedes
contarnos un chiste con tu Tag
un chiste con mucho tiempo
cuando Erick me preguntó cuál era mi tag
Ah pensé te enseñaré algo Erick bien
escuchen Tengo este detalle vean mi
espalda en realidad es muy larga la la
línea de mi trasero es porque creo que
no está permitido
en esto se basan mis chistes en Mostrar
lo larga que es mi espalda ven hasta
donde llega y no pueden ver la línea así
que ese es mi show es lo que he estado
haciendo todo este tiempo
de crédito tengo que insertar un chip
genial y a veces digo que me echaron de
la asociación de fontaneros mi hermana
siempre me decía que tenía una espalda
agujereada y yo pensaba
esto es normal lo baja que está la línea
de mi trasero veré si esto es común con
un con más amplio mi padre se enfadó
conmigo la semana pasada y me llamó
idiota y yo dije papá ya nos llamamos a
la gente Así lo llamamos milenias sí
[Música]
no fumes hierba hasta que llegue a
California estaba en el ejército y los
que fuman hierba Cuando se enteran de
que no lo has hecho te hablan de ella de
la misma forma en que seducen a las
mujeres quieres hacerlo conmigo lo tengo
en mis pantalones y te cambiará la vida
Solo que no interrumpas mi chiste algo
sketch e improviso pero mi acto es tocar
una baguette como un saxofón
[Música]
Y si vendes eso si lo haces durante 5
minutos si puedes poner tu boca en la
baguette y empiezas a soplar eso eso eso
funciona
el otro día Vi Pinocho y pensé esto es
una película sobre una marioneta que se
vuelve más judía
te diré que cierres me lastimé la
espalda haciendo twerking fui yo quiero
práctico y me dijo Cómo sucedió eso le
dije estaba bailando sexy y me dijo su
seguro no cubre casos falsos
No lo entendí y eso está bien Pueden
decir cuál es su lpm Qué significa eso
es cuando corre y me siento el ritmo
cardíaco
yo no lo uso consigo
Ya nadie usa
el lpm ya no se usa eso pero siento que
si estás dentro de la sabes que existe
si lo digo y no sabes de qué hablo no
tienes mucho tiempo aquí Cuánto les
pagan cuando están invitados a un show
te pagan dólares
Tyler parecía por la mirada de miedo en
sus ojos supe que él nunca ha hecho algo
como lo que hago yo en público
vote por él porque
es un buen tipo pero ya me estaba
molestando
entiendo que sea su forma pero eso no es
lo que pienso cuando se habla de comedia
en vivo
está bien Adiós adiós
lo entiende Si creen que el impostor
sigue en la caja y quieren seguir
jugando levanten la mano
bien cada vez que expulsen a alguien que
no sea el impostor el dinero se reducirá
Gracias por decirnoslo después de haber
votado
habías preguntado algo sobre el dinero
algo sobre ser invitado Cuánto cobras
Por eso como el principal deberían pagar
al menos 1500 si estás en un club 800 y
1.200 si eres un invitado unos 300 tal
vez mil dólares si eres bueno
improvisando sospechan de este hombre
después de todas las rondas
seamos sinceros tienes razón tienes
mucha razón
estoy indecisa Isabella James James
interesante tienes mucha confianza y
dices cosas que tienen sentido Pero
trato podrías tener un amigo comediante
si alguien tiene mucha confianza y trata
de probarse a sí mismo eres tú dices
Demasiada información para cada simple
pregunta
me hace pensar que son Auténticos
comediantes están desesperados por la
aprobación del grupo que dicen
información
es enseñar tu trasero por eso estoy un
poco escépticos
innovadora
son únicos
Eso sí es cierto Me olvidé de eso
sí creo que eres tú
usas una camiseta extrañales aquí es
extraño comediante profesional
cada vez que preguntamos te pagan
dijiste que nunca te pagan te
preguntaron y cuándo cierras tu show
cuando te preguntábamos por el cierre
dijiste cuando me digan eso nunca pasó
Cuántos minutos tienes cinco o siete
días Así es como sea
Cuánto tiempo tienes y es un poco como
si estuvieras ensayando por lo general
mis shows toman un poco más de tiempo A
veces hasta 30 minutos yo creo que sí
todos somos porque Alianza dinero todos
formaron una alianza contra mí porque
están celosos de como alguien puede ser
tan bella y tan ágil lo sé lo sé no lo
entienden pensé esperen no traten de
sacarme no soy el impostor no deberían
hacer una alianza de la que yo no soy
parte
lo hacemos muy bien
ya lo sabremos ya lo sabremos
creo que me iré yo pero voté por Michael
por su camiseta
sobreviví a una madre italiana
me pareció que trata de actuar como un
comediante con su ropa muy muy colorida
sí estoy en una alianza una buena
Alianza no sé si me invitaron pero me
uní
[Música]
me despido
Adiós adiós
[Aplausos]
lo sabía la gente no me entiende No
puedo creer que sospecharan de mí no lo
puedo creer
tienes mucha confianza
somos tristes no somos alegres juego si
creen que el impostor sigue en la caja y
quieren seguir jugando levanten la mano
[Música]
bien si las luces se vuelven rojas
significa que el impostor sigue en la
caja y pierden si se vuelven verdes
significa que lo expulsaron y ganan
[Aplausos]
por favor que el impostor salga y se
revele
[Música]
[Risas]
no logramos nadie hace fiesta este
cumpleaños
no le gustan sí sé que dije que él me
molestaba pero en realidad le apasiona
Mostrar lo que sabe es dulce un buen
tipo Mi padre es un comediante es
ventríloco y mi primo mayor también hace
comedia toda mi familia está loca y
llena de comediantes que no son
profesionales pero sin duda lo parece
para estar en una caja y solo hablar
supe que yo todavía posee una habilidad
buena y es Genial porque no tengo otra
habilidad práctica desarrollada
[Aplausos]
sí amigo
[Música]